gardez la france au fond des yeux ni
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène à un peu moins mais
si vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose un tout
petit détail le trophée les valises à
paris ce qui lui arrive à la bulle
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'inattendu la
gauche unie pour des élections
législatives ça n'a rien d'inédit 1 c
c'était déjà le cas il ya 25 ans à
l'époque le parti socialiste avait
composé la gauche plurielle et chacun
défendra sans doute son point de vue
c'est normal sa singularité et l'idée
c'est de faire vivre notre couple
singulier de la majorité parce qu'ils
s'accouplent à 5 le mieux possible mais
c'est jamais facile déjà à deux c'est
compliqué à 3 c'est inattendu alors à 5
c'est miraculeux bonjour de lionel
jospin merci d'être dans l'inattendu
alors la gauche plurielle ce couple a
cinq dont françois hollande pincer votre
oeuvre vous êtes l'artisan cette union
qui a amené la gauche au pouvoir en 1997
et vous à matignon vous y croyez à cette
gauche plurielle version 2022 il ya des
différences je pense moi je suis un fils
de sages-femmes j'ai envie de vous dire
que
la gauche plurielle ça a été une
gestation lente puisque on a commencé
dès 1994 où michel rocard
jean christophe cambadélis et moi même
avons lancé les assises dans la
transformation sociale
ce que nous avons fait en trois ans ils
ont été par les circonstances où leur
désir amené à le faire en trois semaines
donc c'est plutôt un accouchement au
forceps pour garder le même françois
hollande en 1997 parle d'un miracle pour
décrire ce couple à 5 c'est vraiment un
miracle un couple a cinq balles en tout
cas le miracle a duré cinq ans même si
il s'est consumé à la fin un peu
bêtement alors on va remonter le temps
avec vous camille on va planter le décor
oui nous sommes en 1997 jacques chirac
président de la république surprend tout
le monde avec une décision politique
absolument nous sommes en avril 97 le 21
avril précisément et à 20 heures jacques
chirac apparaît sur le petit écran
mes chers compatriotes
après consultation du premier ministre
du président du sénat du président de
l'assemblée nationale
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale
aujourd'hui je considère en conscience
que l'intérêt du pays commande
d'anticiper les élections des élections
anticipées d'un an les élections
législatives étaient prévus en
1998 lionel jospin quand vous entendez
quand vous voyez le président de la
république est ce que les bras vous en
tombent ou est-ce que vous vous
attendiez à cette dissolution non je
suis surpris comme tout le monde et même
les un ou deux amis qui m'avait dit mais
si lyon i pivadis hood je n'y croyais
pas surpris oui nous l'étions mais nous
étions prêts à cause de ce travail qu'on
a commencé à évoquer justement vous
étiez prêt vous étiez premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste à l'époque donc prêt
à la bataille mais depuis quand pendant
deux ans on a fait les conventions il ya
eu tout ce travail des assises de la
transformation sociale ses dialogues
avec les autres forces de gauche et
communistes et socialistes bien sûr
qu'ils étaient des forces plus
importante qu'aujourd'hui sans doute les
communistes les verts les radicaux de
gauche et le mouvement des citoyens de
chevènement nous rejoignant à la fin
disons donc on était prêts on était
prêts on n'a pas fait un accord au
dernier moment comme aujourd'hui
en rassemblant tout le monde on a
discuté le parti socialiste avec chacun
des partenaires alors avant l'avant la
gauche plurielle il ya eu l'explosion du
programme commun mené notamment par
françois mitterrand et georges marchais
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous retournez
à ce rassemblement des gauches c'est le
prix à payer c'est le prix nécessaire
pour accéder au pouvoir mais c'est pas
pour moi un prix mon idée était que si
nous voulions revenir au pouvoir il
fallait à nouveau rassembler ses forces
et effectivement 97 la nouvelle va jory
teva voir les communistes revenir au
pouvoir qu'ils avaient quittée 13 ans
auparavant et les écologistes c'était la
nouveauté entré pour la première fois en
tant que pourtant que parti au
gouvernement alors on va retourner en
1997 avec camille juste après l annonce
de cette dissolution par an mais oui par
jacques chirac mais juste après la
gauche se met donc en ordre de bataille
et le 29 avril huit jours après
l'annnonce de jacques chirac un accord
est bouclée communistes et socialistes
sont retrouvés aujourd'hui pour signer
un document commun qui ne doit pas être
présenté comme un programme de
gouvernement mais comme un accord
électoral
une journée pour l'image dans ses
moindres détails le scénario était écrit
al avance il est 15 heures 10 robert eux
quittent le siège du parti communiste
conversation légère avec ses lieutenants
et en sortent soyons tous les bugs ou
soit que vous deviez pour les
participants l'enjeu pour lui
aujourd'hui c'est de faire profiter son
parti de la dynamique socialiste il est
15h55 la délégation socialiste arrive
juste quelques minutes avant les leaders
c'est le protocole
16h entrée en scène de lionel jospin
aujourd'hui il veut gagner ses galons de
rassembleur de la gauche
rien n'est laissé au hasard ils sont
onze de chaque côté de la table face à
face les hommes de la négociation jean
christophe cambadélis et daniel vaillant
pour le parti socialiste jean claude
gayssot et pierre bleue teint pour le
parti communiste ils travaillent
ensemble depuis cinq mois pressé par la
dissolution ils ont bouclé l'accord
dimanche
vous n'êtes pas juste acteurs de cette
histoire lionel jospin vous en êtes
l'auteur vous n'avez pas dû beaucoup
dormir avec robert hue ces derniers
jours de négociation oui mais en même
temps robert hue c'était la rondeur par
rapport à georges marchais tel que je
l'avais connu des puissants c'était plus
simple je pense qu'il voulait revenir
effectivement dans cette démarche
nouvelle et ce que vous avez été
consultés ces dernières semaines lors
dès lors des négociations entre le ps et
la france insoumis justement lorsqu'il
était question de ces accords désaccords
non je ne peux pas dire que j'ai été
consulté je ne les ayant pas demandé ni
souhaité j'ai été informé de quelques
petits problèmes moi j'avais approuvé la
démarche
les socialistes ont discuté dans des
conditions très difficiles pour eux le
rapport de force avait rien à voir avec
celui que j'avais connu moi et j'avais
bénéficié à une autre époque ils ont
donc fait ce qu'ils ont pu
j'étais d'accord sur la démarche quant à
l'accord j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire il a été peut-être un peu léonins
peut-être à tort d'ailleurs vous
soutenez servi des marges s'appuyer sur
les forces de chacun quand on veut
devenir premier ministre on va revenir
sur les élections législatives de 1997
camille avec l'annoncé des résultats eh
bien oui au soir du second tour le 1er
juin
1997 la gauche plurielle votre gauche
lionel jospin gagne les élections
l'assemblée vous voyez change de couleur
elle rougit le pari est donc gagné de
cette gauche plurielle et on va vous
voir au soir des résultats lionel jospin
vous êtes dans un canapé vous prenez des
notes
est ce que vous attendiez à cette
victoire à partir des résultats du
premier tour je me disais que c'était
possible et j'ai commencé à réfléchir à
ce que pourrait être un gouvernement de
la gauche unie si nous gagnons je
n'anticipais pas mais je savais que je
devais être là aussi près très vite vous
n'avez peut-être pas anticipé alors
votre rendez vous du lendemain puisque
vous allez à l'elysée il est 12h30 très
précise lionel jospin vient de passer
une heure dans le bureau du président de
la république sur le perron de l'elysée
ils officialisent lui même sa nomination
à matignon
simplement le président de la république
c'est de me nommer premier ministre et
j'ai accepté
déjà le nouveau premier ministre repart
tout doit aller très vite il a promis de
faire connaître la composition de son
gouvernement avant la fin de la semaine
alors plus vite que ça même puisque vous
allez former votre gouvernement en à
peine trois jours comme si tout était
prêt pourtant vous vous n'aviez pas
appelé les français à vous élire comme
jean luc mélenchon est ce que nous en
avions envie d'arriver à matignon mais
la question se poserait pas à partir du
moment où nous avions reconstruit une
majorité plurielle où le parti
socialiste avait retrouvé sa force
naturellement nous allions aux élections
qui nous avait surpris pour essayer de
les gagner et les gagnants je savais que
le président jacques chirac ne pourrait
faire appel qu'à moi de la même manière
qu'eux en quatre vingt six le président
mitterrand n'avait pu faire appel qu'à
jacques chirac mais je précise par
rapport à cette annonce je vois l'image
qui apparaît à nouveau que c'est pas du
tout voulu rompre avec les usages quand
je suis sortie de l'entretien avec
jacques chirac ont dit dans je vous
nomme évidemment premier ministre et tu
dis mais je sors ils vont vous demander
qu'est ce que je fais et ce que je leur
dis vous m'avez nommé premier ministre
m'a dit oui c'était son côté simple elle
veut dire et est donc c'est moi qui
l'ait annoncé par le secrétaire général
de l'elysée mais parce que je pouvais
pas faire autrement est-ce que vous avez
un échange avec jacques chirac à ce
moment là où après sur sur son choix de
dissoudre l'assemblée non non j'ai eu
l'élégance nord a reparlé
vous avez sorti qui regrettait un moment
ou pas nancy revenue plus loin dans le
débat un jour jacques chirac parlant des
35 heures avait dit ça alors c'était
vraiment puisqu'il a eu une
expérimentation au hasard et je m'étais
permis de dire dans une réunion de
socialiste que je connaissais une autre
expérimentations hasardeuses qui avait
été la dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale
deux ans après 95 ya un sentiment de
revanche je n'étais pas animé par un
sentiment de revanche mais j'étais animé
par le sentiment de fierté d'avoir pu
reprendre la démarche qui était celle de
françois mitterrand qui m'avait attiré
15 ans avant et d'aboutir finalement ou
succès cette façon originale parce que
ce n'était pas un président de la
république qui a été élu c'était le
premier ministre alors quand jean-luc
mélenchon dit qu'ils veulent se faire
élire premier ministre a peut-être que
ça lui rappelle des souvenirs alors
autre temps fort de cette période
camille la formation du gouvernement le
gouvernement de cette gauche plurielle
oui le gouvernement de cette gauche
plurielle il arrive dans la cour de
l'elysée le 5 juin
1997 et les journalistes sont là pour
immortaliser ce moment
l'arrivée des nouveaux ministres dans la
cour de l'elysée s'est déroulée dans une
ambiance qu'on va qualifier d'assez
particulier un côté rentrée des classes
un peu solennel bien entendu mais aussi
une ambiance montée des marches avec
beaucoup beaucoup de photographes
premier conseil des ministres première
occasion de tester le style j'ose pas
pour la montée des marches de l'elysée
le nouveau premier ministre a fait
simple et sobre juste un temps d'arrêt
devant les photographes située à droite
démarche qui se sentaient un peu
délaissé pour les 26 autres membres du
gouvernement chacun son style arrivés
groupés pour les communistes comme en
les marches du palais c'est un peu comme
au festival de cannes il via les têtes
célèbre déjà vu à la fiche jean pierre
chevènement martine aubry avec son
secrétaire d'état bernard kouchner ou
encore ségolène royal 20 minutes de
conseil des ministres et tout le monde
ressort photo de famille improvisé sur
le perron cohabitation oblige sans
jacques chirac est alors sans jacques
chirac également lionel jospin vous
allez organiser des réunions avec vos
ministres c'est la fameuse méthode
jospin tout le monde autour d'une table
pour discuter avec le recul et
l'expérience que vous avez est-ce que
c'est tenable un gouvernement avec
autour de la table des socialistes des
communistes des écolos oui ça a tenu
cinq ans à l'exception du départ de jean
pierre chevènement qui était un habitué
des départs mais quand on voit les
images là ce qui frappe c'est la jeune
maturité de cette équipe la présence
importante des femmes qui sont dans des
postes régaliens c'est la diversité des
socialistes des communistes des
écologistes
des radicaux
qui oublie le mouvement des citoyens
l'idée d'avoir cette dream team dont on
parlait ça me plaisait qu en tant qu
ancien basketteur bien sûr et bien elle
était pour moi une source de très grande
fierté mais donc c'est effectivement
dans ce lieu que pendant cinq ans
semaine après semaine les ministres une
semaine les ministres et les secrétaires
d'état la semaine suivante ont débattu
des orientations que nous allions
proposer aux français ou plutôt mettre
en oeuvre car les propositions nous les
avions fait avant j'aimerais qu'on vient
à l'instant sur le départ de jean pierre
chevènement de 2,7
union oui un départ en cinq ans qu'est
ce qui s'est passé oui trois ans après
votre arrivée à matignon votre ministre
de l'intérieur cac la porte en 2001
également le gouvernement fait face à
une grogne sociale des manifestations en
france ont lieu contre des licenciements
des plans sociaux des manifestations
soutenues par la gauche a calé pour la
grande manifestation anti plans sociaux
un fossé s'est creusé entre le parti
socialiste ses partenaires de la gauche
plurielle et même sa gauche extrême le
traitement social des nombreux
licenciements et les mauvais résultats
aux dernières municipales accentue le
malaise politique de la gauche
gouvernementale le plus radical et jean
pierre chevènement l'ancien ministre se
demande si la gauche plurielle encore
une raison d'être je crois qu'elle est
une formule épuisé parce qu'elle
reposait d'abord sur une ambiguïté un
accord à géométrie variable entre d'une
part le parti suisse et les verts
d'autre part le parti socialiste et les
communistes et parti de schiste est le
mdc etc et puis on voit bien aujourd'hui
que le parti socialiste ait dépassé par
sa créature est-ce que vous avez été
dépassé par votre créature lionel jospin
non je n'ai pas été dépassé par la
créature qui n'était pas une créature
ans étaient des créateurs c'est
seulement dans l'élection soit par
manque de confiance soit par manque de
loyauté pour l'un d'entre eux que la
gauche s'est dispersée cette fin de
l'union se matérialise par l'élection
présidentielle en 2002 oui 2002 et la
dispersion surtout de la gauche son
candidat jean pierre chevènement robert
hue christiane taubira arlette laguiller
et j'en passe et puis vous vous êtes le
candidat socialiste lionel jospin au
premier tour pas un seul candidat de la
gauche n'est qualifié vous arrivez vous
3e et le second tour se jouait entre
jacques chirac d'un côté jean marie le
pen de l'autre on connaît vos mots
lionel jospin cette année là vous vous
retirer de la scène politique à quel
moment est ce qu'il y a eu un raté dans
l'union des gauches nous ne pouvions pas
gagner l'élection présidentielle avec 5
candidats de chacun des partis de la
majorité plurielle dans une
situation différente avec un candidat
communiste un candidat vert mais le mdc
des radicaux avec moi j'étais sorti en
tête du premier tour si vous faites
l'addition des votes de ses trois
candidats je serai à nouveau sortie
n'est encore je serai à nouveau sorti en
tête du
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle avec cette fois une
chance réelle de gagner ça n'a pas été
possible je les fais celui qui n'en veut
qu'à soi-même après la présidentielle de
2002 un homme membre du parti socialiste
à l'époque ancien ministre de votre
gouvernement pose une question à toute
la gauche le procès en responsabilité
concerne toute la gauche pourquoi
n'at-elle pas été capables de se
rassembler de s'unir si jean luc
mélenchon qui est à la manoeuvre
aujourd'hui qu'a t-il réussi que le
parti socialiste a raté ces dernières
années pourquoi lui at il était capable
de rassembler mon regard est plus nuancé
il a bâti en hâte mais dans une position
sans doute un peu visionique cet accord
alors peut-être que ça ne sera pas trop
tard nous le serons bientôt à la fin des
élections législatives à quoi
ressemblera le parti socialiste dans
dans cinq ans dans dix ans il est menacé
de disparaître il faut trouver une
génération de reconstructeurs je suis un
critique sévère aux républicains mais
sévère de la construction politique
informe qu'à bâti autour de lui et
seulement pour lui le président macron
et je souhaite donc une force que la
gauche se reconstitue
mais trouverons nous les hommes et les
femmes pour le faire cette nouvelle
génération sera t-elle désintéressé et
travailleuses
c'est elle qui apportera la réponse est
moi qui n'auraient pas besoin de
blantyre davantage je les regarderai et
peut-être les accompagnerai ge camille
merci beaucoup pour ce dossier et lionel
jospin vous restez avec nous on va
revenir sur la mise en place de la
proportionnelle en 1986 mais d'abord le
zapping de l'inattendu
[Musique]
pour les facteurs de paris c'est la
course aussi qui est à l'ordre du jour
et un défaut d'un style impeccable on
peut compter sur beaucoup de bonne
volonté et solide émulation
cet après midi georges moustaki a été
inhumé dans le caveau familial du père
lachaise tout à côté de la tombe d'edith
piaf
[Applaudissements]
bien nous pensons que nous devons avoir
des couloirs pour vélo comme ça se passe
dans les pays nordiques regardez en land
vous avez des pistes cyclables à paris
vous n'en avez pas témoin encore
authentique d'un passé vinicole parisien
le quartier de bercy est aujourd'hui en
pleine mutation c'est en effet sur ces
lieux paisibles dévolu depuis 400 ans au
négoce des vins et au vieillissement des
fûts que s'élèvera bientôt le quartier
international du vin et de l'alimentaire
c'est prévient me lavais premier
ministre je lui exprime est
naturellement ma reconnaissance pour la
confiance qui veut bien me faire je vais
maintenant procéder à un certain nombre
de consultations pour la formation du
gouvernement
allons de la tour eiffel le ministre de
l'information monsieur emile hugues a
inauguré un nouveau car destiné à la
télévision française pourra-t-on dire
bientôt que la télévision française est
à la pointe du progrès bonsoir
[Musique]
comment améliorer la représentation des
forces politiques à l'assemblée
nationale alors beaucoup d'élus ils sont
favorables notamment un scrutin
proportionnel même emmanuel macron s'est
dit ouvert à ce système de vote c'était
entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle
bonjour richard poirot la tentation de
la proportionnelle est souvent grande
pourtant sous la vème république une
seule expérience pour les législatives
c'était en 1986 absolument c'était la
volonté du président socialiste françois
mitterrand mais cette modification du
scrutin alors qu'ils étaient
majoritaires a provoqué une véritable
tempête politique la droite a hurlé
littéralement à la manigance avec des
mots très violents
c'était vraiment la combine politicienne
dans toute son horreur la combine
politicienne
ainsi parlait jacques chirac en 1988 à
propos d'un des épisodes les plus
marquants de la vème république
les législatives de 1986 pour la
première et l'unique fois à la
proportionnelle en 1981 françois
mitterrand avait inscrit cette mesure à
son programme présidentiel et en 1985
elle revient au détour d'une
conversation l'infusart est à des degrés
divers de la proportionnelle dans la
plupart de nos au mode de scrutin et les
choses se précisent juste après alors si
l'on parle précisément législatives
c'est le débat pour le gouvernement se
charge pas mon travail mais ce sera
certainement un jeu total dont la
finalité sera proportionnelle mais
l'opposition de droite y voit surtout
une manoeuvre visant à l'affaiblir alors
qu'elle est en tête des sondages
justement pour ces législatives de 1986
c'est scandaleux car on ne change pas
les règles du jeu à la veille d'une
compétition et si le président de la
république le fait si le gouvernement ne
fait c'est parce qu'ils ont peur d'être
battus le vote à la proportionnelle
favorise les petits partis et elle
pourrait surtout affaiblir le rpr ultra
favori en poussant un autre parti qui
lui ne cesse de monter dans les sondages
du front national jacques chirac fut mis
à la proportionnelle c'est bien entendu
l'institutionnalisation de cette extrême
droite alors d'un côté on pousse des
hurlements pour la dénoncer et de
l'autre on fait tout ce qu'il faut
d'abord pour la créer puis pour la
développer et ensuite pour
l'institutionnaliser
l'hypocrisie de ces gens je parle des
gens qui nous gouvernent et quelque
chose de pyramidale la loi électorale et
modifié ce qui n'empêchera pas en mars
86 la droite de remporter les
législatives mais avec une majorité
moins forte que prévu la droite continue
de s'en porter à l'image de
l'éditorialiste du figaro jean
d'ormesson l'instauration de cette
proportionnelle a fait un vainqueur et
un seul et nous rendons grâce au
président de la république de ce succès
c'est le grand succès du front national
pour la première fois en effet le front
national entre à l'assemblée avec 35
députés jean-marie le pen à leur tête le
premier ministre en sursis laurent
fabius le déplore le front national
remporte un nombre important de sièges
ce qui suscitera une inquiétude légitime
chez tous les démocrates jacques chirac
devient premier ministre de cohabitation
est à peine en poste il reviendra aux
modes de scrutins précédents majoritaire
à deux tours le système majoritaire
indissociable des institutions de la
vème république est supérieur au système
proportionnel par du point de vue de
l'efficacité
que du point de vue de la justice
l'expérience des législatives de 86 est
pour l'heure unique
la vème république
[Musique]
lionel jospin vous étiez premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste à lille
vous étiez absolument aux premières
loges donc de ce qui se passe dit à ce
moment là est ce que oui ou non c'était
une manigance pour diviser les voix de
la droite je sais pas si c'était une
manigance mais c'était une manière
discutable le mans un calcul politique
je vais y revenir mais disons qu'on
manque une chose puisque nous sommes en
2022 pas en 1986 le scrutin majoritaire
auquel ont des revenus depuis et qui n'a
pas changé n'a pas empêché semble-t-il
le front national de prospérer donc
rétrospectivement abandonné aux procès
mais revenons sur l'histoire je dirais
que la proportionnelle instauré en
1985 pour les élections de 86 étaient
prophylactique elle était défensive elle
voulait nous protéger effectivement du
risque d'un raz-de-marée rpr udf alala à
l'assemblée nationale et rendre la
cohabitation plus difficile je crois
qu'il faut le reconnaître nettement et
je lui ai d'ailleurs déjà écrit dans des
livres mais il faut bien comprendre en
même temps que aujourd'hui à nouveau on
parle de proportionnelle ce qui veut
dire que le procès rétrospective
n'empêche pas tous les présidents de la
république et non en tout cas les
derniers d'avoir tous voulu une dose de
proportionnelle donc nous verrons si
c'est dose de proportionnelle
destiné à mieux représenter les forces
minoritaire ou d'opposition sera
effectivement décidé par le président de
la république quelle gouvernance ça
serait une bonne chose selon vous une
dose de proportionnelle je ne suis pas
du tout hostile à la proportionnelle
dans une mesure relativement modérée
mais c'est aujourd'hui à ceux qui sont
au pouvoir de le décider enfin donc
qu'il cesse d'en parler
qu'il passe aux actes lionel jospin
merci pour vos explications votre
éclairage sur ces sur ses années
politique tiens vous allez peut-être
sourire à la séance qui suit c'est notre
traditionnel et pitt de l'ina
[Musique]
et nous sommes en 1991 le débat sur la
proportionnelle inspire beaucoup de
monde y compris certains humoristes
comme jacques martin regardez
ce ne sera pas bézef ça ne sera pas
bézef pour les gens de l'ue pf pour les
gens de l'ubs et l'upm
par des êtres amusants groupuscule vous
messieurs les calculs et délices et des
dix extrémistes elle s'est mise écolo
rigolo dans le dos dans le dos et les
voix et les voir dans le baba
[Musique]
voilà la proportionnelle peut nous faire
sourire les chars poireau merci beaucoup
pour cet éclairage sur la
proportionnelle encore une fois merci
lionel jospin de nous avoir accompagnés
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine sur
le canal 27 et toute la semaine sur les
réseaux sociaux que ce soit ce dinars ou
ceux de france info émission préparée
avec les documentalistes et les honneurs
privé au corps lieu et le visage barney
merci également à toute l'équipe qui a
préparé c'est inattendu à bientôt
[Musique]